what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here today I'm going to watch injustice
to introducing enchantress trailer
[Music]
[Music]
his personal reversing Deadshot clear
[Music]
nice cool
what
and knives is a go teleportation
[Music]
damn
I hope you too submissive time more oh
here we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
damn how do you beat someone like that
you see like when I play injustice - I'm
great
with a character like Robin you know
when it comes down to just kicks and
punches when it comes to like crazy-ass
combo maneuvers that can be a little bit
tougher for me especially in this game
but I feel like if you know how to use
in chant receives all these magic
abilities it might be very hard to
defeat whoever you're playing against
because she can hit you from not that
far away with her magic abilities and I
like that finishing move were like a
hologram magic form of you comes out and
attacks you
looks pretty scary actually this this
should have been the Enchantress in
Suicide Squad right here this would have
been a great enchantress because that is
intimidating those are some kickass
powers right there Tony Gilliam coming
for you next time we play buddy I'm
gonna kick your ass and you pay the
money to download her because I'm not
going to it's your game subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
Valley you follow us all over social
media including our patreon have a lot
of exclusive videos over there obviously
more movie related type of content but
go check it out a lot a lot have over
300 posts on patreon right now so go
check it out